los ministros de defensa de la otan
reunidos hoy en bruselas aseguran que
están extremadamente preocupados por la
situación en la frontera entre ucrania y
rusia el secretario general de la otan
jens stoltenberg por el momento asegura
que no hay ningún tipo de escalada
militar y que no hay retirada de momento
ni de tropas ni de cambio ni de
equipamiento militar por lo que están
observando es más según stoltenberg hay
incluso un aumento de tropas en el
terreno en todo caso los ministros y
stoltenberg han pedido a rusia que haya
cambios verdaderos porque a día de hoy
rusia mantiene tal despliegue militar
que podría atacar en cualquier momento
desde crimea hasta de la rusa el mayor
aumento de tropas desde la guerra fría
en europa aseguran desde la alianza la
otan ha recordado aún así que sigue
estando preparada para mantener el
diálogo con rusia y de hecho esto al
temer que ha asegurado que ve con cierto
optimismo las intenciones de moscú de
mantener las discusiones pero de momento
ahí están solo son palabras así que por
el momento los ministros de defensa de
la otan también han acordado que haya la
posibilidad de aumentar tropas en el
flanco oriental de la alianza es decir
en países como bulgaria y rumanía algo
que puede ocurrir en las próximas
semanas por último hoy además se ha
anunciado que los líderes europeos que
además se reúnen mañana aquí en bruselas
una reunión con la unión africana
previamente hablarán sobre las tensiones
entre ucrania y rusia